before she was a royal Duchess gracing
the cover of every tabloid magazine and
the subject of a pretty polarizing media
frenzy Meghan Markle was a successful
actress activist and self-proclaimed
foodie with her very own food Vlog the
tig what does it take I don't know alas
she's now the subject matter of
countless tick tocks unpacking every
scene from the recent Netflix reality
series Harry and Megan and while the
world seems to be pretty divided on team
Royal or team mnh here is not the place
for debate today we're focusing on the
food as i embarked e like a Royal or
ex-royal I guess whatever current
situation may be I'll be attempting to
eat like Meghan Markle for a day hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video I'll be eating like
actress turned Duchess of Sussex Meghan
Markle but obviously not quite because
my needs are unique so I'm gonna be
using her alleged meals as a template
for teaching gent nutrition and
inspiring what I make that works for me
and my body also a reminder that this
diet was really compiled from different
primary and secondary sources so I
cannot speak to its legitimacy or
accuracy or whether or not it's up to
date and reminder this is just what I
ate on a random day and it's not meant
to be copied or recommended as how you
should eat always speak to a registered
dietitian about your unique needs Abby
let's do it so like most of the rest of
the world I watched the Oprah interview
and then the Netflix documentary and now
I'm reading Harry's book and now you've
written all about it in your new book
where I have a lot of thoughts which of
course I would love to talk about but
I'm gonna try to put the drama aside for
a hot minute to focus on the food and
I'm gonna try to ask you guys in the
comment section to try to do the same it
just feels a little too early around
here to be digging deep into racism and
mental health issues and family drama
you know anyways speaking of early let's
talk about coffee
so when I tried to look up Megan's
coffee order things were coming up nil
which is really surprising considering
the media has kind of been up her ass
just reporting on seemingly minuscule
things like wearing a messy bun or
closing her own car door so yeah I'm
kind of surprised that the whole coffee
order didn't make the cut but what I do
know is that while she was in Toronto
shooting suits she was really into her
Nespresso maker and then she took like a
break from coffee when she moved to the
UK and she only just started drinking
coffee again fascinating I know we also
know that Megan recently invested in a
coffee startup called clever so I think
it's fair to say that Megan's a coffee
girly like me so according to the
website clever is an adaptogenic base
powder that contains coffee probiotics
and adaptogenic mushrooms which claims
to offer stable energy without the
jittery crash Abby does this sound legit
so when we take a closer look at this
ingredient list we can see that clever
contains Asha Uganda for stress
reduction Lions mean for brain health
and reishi mushrooms for immunity now
starting with the ashwagandha we
actually do have some promising research
that it may be effective at helping to
reduce stress so for instance one study
found that 88 of participants reported a
reduction in stress from supplementing
with ashwagandha same thing goes for the
lion's mane with research showing that
it may help to reduce anxiety and
depression and may even help to protect
against Alzheimer's as for the reishi
mushroom the research on its impact on
immunity is highly mixed and it's really
unclear if they're more effective for
folks who are already ill versus healthy
individuals so the verdict is still out
on that one as for whether or not this
specific brand of coffee could help to
reduce a caffeine-induced energy crash
well we may or may not have ashwagandha
to thank for that while we definitely
need more research to understand these
effects one reason study did find that
caffeine blended with ashwagandha may
help with the slow release of caffeine
to prevent an energy crash later on on
top of that due to its calming effects
ashwagandha may also help to relieve
caffeine Jitters for folks who are
particularly sensitive to caffeine
sounds promising but probably not going
to do anything for me that my
supplements and my actual legitimate
anti-anxiety medications are already
doing so I'm just gonna do her oat milk
latte and take my supplements on the
side cheers
um
yeah so I'm hungry let's talk about
breakfast back in the day when Megan was
here in Toronto shooting suits she
apparently was a regular at this little
kind of juice bar place in Yorkville
called revita size I think I've actually
been there before they have good soups
if I recall anyways she would apparently
order like the acai Bowl two to three
times a week and I managed to get the
basic recipe to make at home unpopular
opinion folks but actual acai kind of
tastes like like it is so overwhelmingly
bitter it requires so much sugar to make
it palatable not to mention I get that
it's been branded as an amazing
superfood but blueberries cherries and
other red berries are really not that
far off so I'm gonna work with what I
already have in the freezer and turn it
into a hunger crushing combo let's do it
okay so according to the recipe this is
just supposed to be one acai packet on
Milk Banana frozen berries that's it
it's a good start but I know for me I
cannot live on just like Blended up
berries alone so I'm gonna throw in
barbaries
I got frozen banana as per the recipe I
got a little spinach and a little kale
we'll do it like a tiny nugget of each
might as well get some veg in there
now some kind of source of protein is
key this could be protein powder I'm
using a nice full fat Greek yogurt it's
going to add some fat it's going to add
some body and it's going to add a ton of
protein
I think we'll drizzle the peanut butter
on top all right a little honey
this thing oh
again most prepared YouTube channel in
the world yep well
someone's getting fired today they're
gonna take the lid off all right and
then our almond milk
okay let's blend her up
[Music]
I don't know why I spend money on these
things they never work
s we'll just mash them by hand stomp on
them just like yeah just like making
wine baby making wine
foreign that's pretty good there's a
little chunk but it's par for the course
all right
this looks so good
you know I like always totally forget
about making a smoothie Bowl
you got to do like this kind of thing
but it actually is really delicious
mmm
a little swirl
nice some banana
it's not a hair or is that just like
no it's like banana goop
banana goop strings
that's new for me hmm
all right
grapes in what world would a princess
be styling her own bowl like this no
world no such world but you know what
like I don't even have time to style a
wool like this normally proof that
YouTube is not real life
okay some hemp hearts
[Applause]
and then she apparently also really
likes coconut and I love it
oh it's like snow just beaut
okay so even though in real life I would
never take the time to assemble a bowl
that looks as Instagram worthy as this I
am not mad about it I am quite proud of
this masterpiece I also really love the
idea of a smoothie Bowl because it means
that we get to sit down and really be
more mindful about each and every bite
it's really easy to just chug down four
or five hundred calories of a smoothie
on the go and not really taken any
sensory feedback about the experience
but this on the other hand I'm Gonna
Save her
um
[Music]
but it's good all right now that we're
fueled and caffeinated let's take a look
at Megan's workout routine I love
running but I think I think you have to
find a work a workout routine that
really speaks to you beyond trying to
get goals for your body so for me
running is like I need as much for my
head and to clear my head as I do for
keeping in shape so I love to jog I do a
lot of hot yoga milkshake yoga
specifically and then Pilates love this
exercise philosophy Abby do you agree
yes honestly I feel like more often than
not we lose sight of exercise for
purposes Beyond just weight loss
especially when most high profile celebs
work out exclusively to shed pounds for
a role or a particular dress okay
excuse me but I actually has a
with weight loss including improvements
in energy levels mood cognitive function
regularity Sleep Quality and even
improved blood markers like cholesterol
and blood pressure so I love that Megan
tunes into how certain exercises make
her feel both physically and mentally
and also isn't afraid to diversify her
workout routine based on what feels good
for her I am admittedly not a runner
thanks to the damage that two kids have
done to my pelvic floor but I can
definitely get down for some Pilates
let's go for it
foreign
[Music]
folks I'm feeling the snack attack come
on really effing strong so I'm gonna
need a little something to get me into
lunch I'm real luck because one of
Megan's favorite snacks is also one of
my go-to favorites so she loves hummus
with crackers and veg simple but
effective okay so I had to get Megan's
favorite crackers these are Mary's
organic and they are definitely really
nutrient dense so one serving of 12
crackers has three grams of fiber and
four grams of protein so really awesome
and a really super simple ingredient
list so we got some Protein healthy fats
in our hummus plus some fiber rich carbs
in our veg and crackers and I read this
article that Megan wrote in today where
she described this specific snack in
really kind of sensual words so she
described you know the creamy mouth feel
and the crunchy taste and the the Savory
flavor
I don't think it matters what anyone's
politics are on Megan herself but we
love when a girl romanticizes food
and this really is like a perfect little
love triangle
it is officially lunch time and the
hanger is hangering and according to
Megan she loves to honor her California
Roots by tucking into some really
delicious Baja style fish tacos again
California girl grew up having a lot of
fish tacos you don't have to ask me
twice I am a huge Taco fan so I'm gonna
get chopping some accompanying veg Abby
can you go over how to choose a
sustainable fish you got it Abby it's
unfortunately not as straightforward as
choosing farmed over wild caught or vice
versa as it will depend on the location
how it was caught and the fish itself so
for example Farm tilapia from Peru is a
highly rated option but farmed from
China is not while wild caught Pacific
Cod is another highly rated pick but
Atlantic Cod is on the avoid list so
your best bet is to look for a seafood
that's being certified by a regulatory
organization like the aquaculture
Stewardship Council muscle Global
sustainable Seafood initiative or
Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood watch all
right little olive oil I'm using a
sustainable American Dover soil
because that's what my fishmonger had on
sale this week
salty salt
all right we're gonna make a quick
little sauce here
sour cream Touch of mayo all right some
tahin
okay A little bit of that oh yeah a lot
of that and some lime juice
a little cabbage crunch a little sauce
action
some crumbled feta
all right that was surprisingly quick
and easy and it's also inherently super
well balanced so we've got protein in
our fish healthy fats in our avocado
some carb action in our tortillas and
lots of fiber-rich veg a little squirt
squirt
hmm
the feta
Next Level it is 3 P.M and that energy
slump is hit and heard so let's take a
look at one of Megan's favorite snacks
definitely a green juice I mean I think
trying to go for coffee or things like
that only end up hurting you at the end
so to get like a really good natural
source of energy like a great green
juice or even kombucha I'll have some
time something that just gets right into
your system is a nice pick-me-up I can
get down with a little cold pressed
juice situation every now and then
um but Megan's recipe is more like a
smoothie to me because she basically
just Blends together Apple uh kale or
spinach lemon ginger with almond milk
we're gonna see how it goes like with
the acai Bowl I feel like that's just
not going to keep me very satiated for
very long so I'm gonna use a protein
almond milk and I'm gonna throw in the
rest of my avocado for some healthy fats
let's see how it goes we got apple
run away
a little fresh ginger a little frozen
kale
just a bit because I already feel like
this recipe is a bit of a stretch a
little bit of lemon juice
well
sounds pit
all right almond milk this is weird this
is very weird
and let's get the rest of that avocado
in there oh
it's we're having a day here folks it's
Friday and I am over
over making my snacks from scratch
all right let's blend this
oh no
that is not a pick-me-up friends that is
a put me down
as with most smoothie recipes that I try
that suck I feel like a banana will
remedy the situation
actually not bad not great but not bad
we have finally made it to the end of
our Royal day in the life and I am ready
for a dinner fit for a duchess AKA pasta
we love a Carby and to a day so Megan
apparently swears by her recipe for this
zucchini pasta which she apparently
calls filthy sexy mush
I want to Workshop the title but I'm
definitely intrigued on what this
exactly entails apparently apparently
sauce only really requires three simple
ingredients zucchini water and bouillon
I got those things she claims that a
humble zucchini will turn into this like
buttery creamy sauce and I just like
cannot wait to try it so let's get
chopping up some veg alright so this
seems pretty straightforward it's just a
zucchini chopped up real fine
hopefully not my finger
we're gonna give this a go olive oil
I think that's really key in this case
because the sauce is not a whole lot
else
we got our chopped zucchini
I'm gonna add some generous salt to
action and pepper
and we'll let that just cook ingredient
two bouillon
oh
one second Brody she's rolling
bundle of bucatini because I'm busting
out my favorite pasta for this for the
Royal Treatment
okay don't don't show this part birdie
don't no one has to know
no one has to know that I didn't have 90
minutes to wait for zucchini to Mush
down I had to turn it into baby food
this mush needs some proteins so I've
got some white beans just going to throw
them down drained and rinsed
we got our bucatini warm I feel like
without nooch this is going to be
really flavorless so I'm loading up
looks like pesto actually
let's plate her up apparently Megan's
favorite dessert is a glass of wine and
I'm not mad about it so let's put this
little meal together shall we
it's been a day a little cheese
so we got fiber in the melted down
zucchini Plus in the white beans protein
in the white beans which I added and
also in the nooch healthy fats in the
olive oil that I cooked with and some
carbs in the pasta
it's surprisingly really good nice job
team like I was skeptical about the
prospects of a pasta sauce without
onions and garlic but I'm really glad I
tried it because this is definitely kind
of like a low FODMAP option and the
bouillon actually adds just enough
flavor and kind of salty bite that it is
really satisfying hmm Megan I'm
impressed
I gotta say that this day of eating left
me feeling royally satisfied and it does
seem on brand for Megan as she is being
quoted as saying that it's important to
balance decadent treats that make the
heart go pitter-pet and nourishment that
fuels my body I love that and it really
doesn't matter to me what your like
personal or political opinions on Megan
are I honestly like personally don't
care enough to pass judgment but I just
love when a celebrity or influential
person has an attitude around food like
this so I definitely just try to avoid
the things that I know are going to make
me feel lethargic or sluggish and if you
deprive yourself of anything you're just
going to Crave it more so for me it's
just finding that balance that is a
great real world example of intuitive
eating and gentle nutrition when you
give yourself unconditional permission
to eat the foods that you love you're
much better able to tune into your
body's cues when it says like you know
what
um
maybe that doesn't feel so good fan or
no fan I think we can all get on board
with an eating philosophy like this and
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on Whose diet you'd like
to see me try next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye foreign
[Music]